it has been almost a week now since
metro police officer Trung Tai was
killed in the line of duty we do thank
you for joining us here at 11 I'm Denise
Valdez and I'm Brian Loftis while family
and fellow officers grieve his legacy is
running strong thanks to a 10 year old
girl Ryan mathey joins us live from the
south end of the strip with the mile
long memorial for officer Tai
well Brian Denise we've seen several
parts of the boulevard blocked off
before never by a fifth grader she and
several metro police officers ran down
this stretch of the strip today all for
fallen officer trong tie Ty's family
running alongside these officers today
for the man that they say left his mark
on the valley
first I started running for October 1st
for the 58 Angels ten-year-old Teresa
Ann loves to run but for a purpose since
the age of four she's raised money for
fallen and injured police officers and
canines through lemonade stands and
running she's ran for Charles Hartfield
Chad parquet some officers that have
passed here locally but this one is more
special she and her dad Robert Babcock
doing this fundraising through their
non-profit running for Heroes on
Wednesday afternoon they ran for another
hero Fallen metro police officer trong
Tai who was shot and killed last week
while on duty
the fifth grader leading over 20 metro
police officers a mile down the strip
from the Excalibur down to the South
Central Area commands near the welcome
to Las Vegas sign a police escort
blocking oncoming traffic we're
overwhelmed
um
speechless even officer Ty's niece Janet
says her uncle was like a father she ran
behind young Teresa's group sharing in
her family's grief this run she says
keeps his legacy on track we're so
grateful and it's so hard to say thank
you and every time I see any Metro
officer like our family just wants to
hug each and every single one I know
that they're feeling the loss just as
much as we are
I would have said thank you for your
service and you're a great hero
Aflac you saw her running with is
donated to the Thai family to
commemorate the day today and Teresa's
father you heard from she says the point
of any run she partakes in is to bring
awareness to the ultimate sacrifice
police risk every day reporting live
from the southern end of the strip Ryan
Matthey 8 News Now